Programming Throwdown, Episode 185 Workflow orchestrators. Take it away, Patrick. Welcome to another guaranteed to be fantastic episode. That's right, yeah, it's money back. I nailed it. We've been doing this too long. Okay. I'm going to try something a little different.
I was thinking about this. I don't have a good formulation of it. So you can sort of help me. All right. But it's sort of been coming up in a number of things. And the sort of most obvious one is when people talk about venture capital, which is, you know, investors, mostly tech investors. And they invest in, you know, 100 companies. But really, they're expecting sort of tend to do really well.
they're hoping the rest don't, you know, they just assume they basically go to zero, they kind of don't care, and then they hope, you know, one or two, 1,000 X or whatever and pay for the risk they take over the entire pool.
And, you know, part of that is this sort of like asymmetric returns. And then I began thinking, it pops up in sort of other things. You know, people were talking, you know, most recently I was listening to someone talking about, about health recommendations,
like how much protein should you consume? And people have this, you know, oh, maybe you did this much, maybe that much, maybe. And then we sort of said, you know, up to a certain point, it kind of, you know, is very, very important. And then past another point, you know, it's, you kind of get this like nonlinear relationship. And then I began to think about it. And they kind of said something that led me to thinking about it in terms of, in terms of work,
which is if you set a certain target goal for how much you learn, you know, in a given day or continual learning or, you know, how much output you want at work, I think. internally we have this, you know, sort of everything gets kind of normally distributed that maybe some days you're going to be a little bit above, some days a little bit below, some days, you know, very rarely a lot above, you know, very rarely a lot below. And in my head, at least, you know, I think we do this thing that pops up intuitively over and over again where things kind of clump together and become sort of normally. And we think that the returns there end up being, you know, kind of not super impactful, like they even out, basically, that the unders
and the overs, overs, you know, are okay. But what I began to realize, and sorry, trying to bring it full circle, it's a little cloudy in my mind, but back to the VC thing, this health thing, that they were sort of saying, you kind of need to set your targets a little higher, because actually, depending on where you are on this sort of like return curve, right, that is not flat. it's not, you know, just one single slope that if you are at one of these inflection points or lower, then the good days can be sort of 10x and the bad days are, you know, negative some amount. And if you're really low, what ends up happening is those negative amounts are sort of larger than the big amounts and you can sort of lose ground or, you know, not move
forward versus if you're higher up on the curve and you set your target, then even the low days, you know, you're still sort of moving forward. And so when I talk about like learning or output at work, if you, you know, sort of set your target as like my median is I get a little bit of good stuff done. And some days I get a lot. Some days I don't. Some days I make more work for myself by doing something stupid or saying something dumb at work, right? You kind of think about this as like evening out to like slow, small steps. But in reality, setting yourself up for at least some of those home runs. So setting yourself up. positionally but also just where your target is like in how you expose yourself it sort of drifts
away sorry my analogy is breaking but like you sort of shift yourself into a position where you're you know you still have days that are below average but you're above average days give you this exposure opportunity for just outsized growth right you're taking those really really hard home runs at work you're you know going for just you know really stretch opportunities and thinking about this you know it's just an interesting thing i've been juggling with which is i think a lot of myself included a lot of the time I don't give myself this opportunity to have this sort of outperformance, this exposure, this VC 1000X, right? You know, we talk about investment. You do the boring. Everyone always says, just put all your money in the S&P 500 or the Russell
5,000, you know, just put all your money in there, this very average dot return. But maybe some amount of it, maybe some small amount, you got to take those like really big swings and you've got to limit it. But if it, you know, 1,000x, it could carry the whole portfolio. Yeah. So I can I can riff on this. I mean, so I don't know if I mentioned this in a past episode, but there's an awesome book from Nassim Nicholas Taleb, The Black Swan. Have you read The Black Swan? Yes. Yep. Yeah. So, yeah, I'm a big proponent that there are black swans and there are white swans. In other words, like, there are... Wait, is white swan the opposite of Black Swan? Well, White Swans, okay, first of all, white swam is a term I literally just made up five seconds ago. But the white swans, but the white swans is the term, but the white swans. I would define it as like, you know, it's an unexpectedly high return. Okay, okay. Because by definition, using your VC example, you know, the VC funds, I've heard things like
they do 100 companies and they expect one company to make up for the other 99, so it's even more extreme. But so what that means is if put yourself in the chair of a VC, when you talk to one of these hundred companies, you know, you're kind of a. expecting them to fail because, you know, statistically, they're going to be one of the 99, right? And at some point, you know, you figure out which one the one is, I'm sure. But I would consider that kind of like, like you're betting on a opposite of a black swan. Like, you're betting on an unexpected, like huge boom, right? And so, yeah, I think that, you know, otherwise you wouldn't,
you wouldn't really take the risk, right? If there wasn't the opposite of a, let's call it the white swan, the white swan wasn't there, the VC wouldn't do what they do, right? If one company, you know, 5xed and the other 99 went to zero, that wouldn't work. So they're kind of counting on that. And I think that is kind of a good way to look at things. I think that there's sort of certain moments where you have kind of eureka moments, or you have kind of a burst or you just get lucky.
And so kind of budgeting for those kind of moments, I think makes a lot of sense. And being kind of ready to really capitalize. That's the other thing is the VC hopefully is set up to where, you know, when they do find the one, that they can then, you know, 10x triple down on that one. So same kind of thing. Like you're constantly kind of exploring.
You see something pretty exciting. and then you kind of bet big on it. I do think that most returns are asymmetric. Oh, the other part I was going to say is, your example with investing, I think that at a large enough scale, things start to become normally distributed, right? So in other words,
like if Broadcom has like a killer year, well, it doesn't really matter if you've invested. in, I don't know if they're in the SMP 500, but if you, if you invested in all SMP 500, then their killer year gets sort of diluted, right? So like at scale, you don't really have black swans or white swans, at least you hope, which is the reason why we can all be sort of comfortable. We're not just anxiety ridden as, as we get older, right? So I think that that at scale, when I think about investing, as someone who's not a very,
savvy investor at all, you know, I just think, well, their returns are going to be normally distributed around 5% or 8% or whatever it is. But then individually, or when I look at things at a smaller scale, I do think the returns are often asymmetric. Yeah, I think I might have mixed up sort of two things I might not. So the one your Rift-on is good. So I think there's like taking it to career growth, not that we always have to talk about that, but taking, I actually believe I I was bringing this up the other day. Most places, we overestimate the impact of a failure. Like, if you really, if your boss came and asked you, hey, do you want to try this like really hard thing? You're like, I'm like, I'm not sure. Like, what's really the downside of failing? Like, I think most of the time in most cases, in all cases, you know, this is not universal advice. I'm not a lawyer, I guess. But like most cases, the risk of failing is pretty low. So it's actually really capped to the downside, you know. And, And it's, I guess, maybe similar to the VC example. The chance of the VC having money taken away from them is non-existent.
So the worst case is capped at zero, but the top case is uncapped. So if they do really bad, if 100 out of 100 fail, they lose all their money that they invested. But it doesn't mean they invested all their money. Correct. But if one goes to Facebook scale or whatever, you know, then all of a sudden, you know, they're filthy rich. And so I think that's probably a good mapping. I think there's another thing I was trying to slide in there,
but maybe now thinking about it, I muddy the water. I think it's separate, which is just like individual performance day to day. So like taking opportunities and getting that exposure, but then day to day, trying to set yourself up so that like, like you're getting the reps in,
you're getting practice in, like you're getting yourself like training and skill and like setting your expectations for yourself maybe higher, knowing that sometimes you're not going to do as well, and then realizing when you practice being at a higher level that you're going to get similarly, it's not exactly the same though, I guess, but you're going to get those outperformance days.
And those outperformance days may shock you with just, like I've had that before. You call it kind of like Eureka moment. You're like doing some work. And being up at that higher level, you're going to potentially see more of them where it's just like, what was I thinking that? It was amazing.
Like, how do I get that in a bottle? Like, I would love to be like that every day. And it doesn't happen often, but I do feel like it happens more often when I'm operating at a high, not burning out, but when I'm expecting more out of myself and performing at a high level. Yeah, I think that makes a lot of sense. I think that similar to the VC, you know, having that money to invest in the next round, like you also need to balance your work and life so that when you do have like that eureka moment, you can kind of really triple down on that. And then go back to a more healthy state. So I think, I don't know if we have a term for this in my family, but, but there is kind of like this notion, like, oh, you know, dad's going into some workhole, you know, he's going to come back in like a couple of days or something.
I call it the fugue, but yeah. The fugue? Yeah, isn't that like an organ thing where like the organ music gets really loud and like, you know. Oh, look at you. I've never, never, that's an SAT word I've never heard. I have to look it up. Maybe, yeah, a fugue state. Here we go.
In music. Yeah, it's a fugue state is a disassociated. It's a psychological environment. So I'm unexpected. Oh, wait, this is bad. No, this is like you have amnesia. What? I completely, okay, maybe I'm thinking, I guess I'm thinking of it.
Oh, Patrick's going dementia again, girls. Oh, no. Oh, no. Hang on. I don't know. Maybe I'm just using this wrong. Oh, well. It's a word.
Like you said, maybe you just need to define a new word. It's like a flow state. That's why I think the like, you know, anyways. Okay, but yeah, I just made up a new word for it apparently because this doesn't match any existing definition. So if you use this, don't expect anyone to know what it is. You know, just, okay, kind of, maybe this is too much of a segue, but you made me think of another thing. I used to coach, you know, high level I sees at Facebook. So basically, I mean, obviously, like there's, I wasn't the highest level.
So there's people above me and everything. But specifically, people who are trying to go either from five to six or six to seven, I did a bunch of one-on-one coaching, and then I ran this thing called the IC Circle, where we would just do more like one-to-many coaching, but it was more of like a community type thing. And one thing really struck me. This person said they didn't want, this was one-on-one. They said they didn't want to go to level six. because if you look at the stats,
you're something like 15 times more likely to get fired if you're level six than if you're level five for performance. And they're like, well, you know, I kind of want to take this promotion. They also were, I think they were on a visa. I mean, it's definitely part of it. But they just felt like, well, my expected value is zero if I get fired.
And so keeping that probability low, is uh actually yeah but you're looking yeah i guess it's not zero you get a job somewhere else but my point is like your your expected value at meta is zero if they fire you right um but uh and and so the the the raise that the level six compensation is higher but not higher enough to justify that right so anyway what i told what i told this person at the time was um was was basically you know okay i totally get it there is and there I think there was kind of an issue with this people at six and above just getting getting fired for performance I said but you know plan for the future don't really plan for the present so like okay the present situation is you're looking around
and you're seeing the level six is on your team getting getting sit home but that's you can't kind of base the future on the present um and I think that that um but I think that, yeah, you have to kind of, like the asymmetric returns kind of kicks in where, you know, by taking that chance and getting, getting that promotion now, you know, you can always kind of figure out your steady state afterwards. What you can't do, or it's very hard to control, is having that amazing, you know, product launch that causes you to get a promotion. Like, in other words, If you have an asymmetric return and you don't capitalize on it, it might be very, very hard to bounce back from that. But if you do capitalize on it, and then let's say, worst case, you know, you get fired for performance at the next level, I still feel like that was the right call. And just to finish the story out, the person didn't get fired. They're actually still at Facebook happily at their level. So, I mean, this got talked about not me, but by people in the field, financial people when Facebook was.
doing the outsized bonuses for hiring AI people. I think they've turned it down now, but they were saying a little bit of a similar thing, there's an expectation of a continuing current state. So in other words, I don't have to take this right now because I could take it in 12 months or 24 months. And in reality, actually it turned out,
it was like a window of like 30 days. Yeah. It was like really short. But it's sort of to what you were saying, those opportunities you think they're, they're going to come at some even spacing or always and it's that's not right it's not true your ability to get a promotion your ability to be on that project your ability to start something new greenfield make your mark whatever those things aren't evenly distributed in time and so yeah i yeah i agree with
you all right so just to follow up i i did find the correct definition of you i wasn't that crazy although it apparently have a slightly negative connotation but it means to do something where you're completely aware and focus but afterwards you can't remember what happened. And so that sounds perfect. That's actually exactly what. So actually it took me a little bit of searching. Apparently it's a very deep, like a back catalog definition. It's like what, what idiot wrote this code? And it was you a week ago. Yes. No, no. That's what I like you get really focused and you turn out all this stuff. My new one is writing code and then like having other people sort of help me like finish it off or whatever and then submit it under their names. And then I think they wrote the code.
and they're like, no, you wrote this code. Oops. All right. All right. Time for news. You're up first. All right. I'm up first.
So it won't be this weekend when this comes out, but that's okay. Just recently, Andre Carpathy, I believe is how you say his name. You know, he's gained some renown recently for a little bit being the people's AI person, I guess. Like, you know, he's not running a big AI company. He clearly knows. knows what he's doing, he can explain concepts, but he explains them in depth. Let me, let me add a little bit of color there. So Andre was the head of AI Tesla, and he left, and he basically is like, I don't want to say retire. That's not the right word because he's very
productive, but he quit to do exactly this, like to just build things for the people and teach the people. And so he's, he's in a way like doing some monastic work right now. well do we talk about SAT words monastic oh there we go look at this man you think people thought they were coming here to talk about programming so you know in some ways actually I think to your thank you for that actually that's color comment is very good you know I think our podcast tries to be although I don't say we're as effective as this something in a similar vein trying to break down stuff for folks he released a new
GitHub repo, sort of out of the blue, as far as I know, I don't think he was, I didn't know he was working on it, called NanoChat. And NanoChat is, previously he had done some other sort of examples of training, I don't say like toy, but like Toy Transformer networks and models and getting them up to sort of GPT2 level, sort of, you know, trying to be two level. Like, like, wow, okay, it's just better than if you, if you remember, oh, I don't know, a while ago, a decade ago, people were doing hidden Markov models trained on, you know, Harry Potter. And it would produce words that, like, if you didn't look too closely, they kind of look like maybe sentences, but they didn't make any sense. And then, you know, we kind of got into the chat GPTs. These GPDs
are good. So he's sort of done some of that before. But now sort of what he's done is done an end-to-end, pre-training, doing the chat UI, you know, constructing the models and everything end-to-end in a single repost. You can really kind of study it. And really awesomely, if you don't know, training the frontier models, I don't even know what the estimates are now like $10 million to train to train one. They're very, very, very expensive. So most training outside of the
maybe 10 companies in the world is doing fine-tuning, you know, other small things, but not the sort of pre-training. That's reserved for people have much more money to burn than myself. Yeah, and 10 million, I think, just is one instance.
So it's like if you miss a colon, I mean, you're going to catch earlier than that. But like in theory, If you have some data issue, now it's another 10 million. Yeah, yeah, yeah. You know, who knows how many times they have to do it. Yeah, that's right. And that was a big thing.
If you were called Deep Seat getting really popular for, you know, they had their moment. They've kind of, you know, taken a little step back, you know, in terms of in the, you know, general awareness. But that was their big thing was doing some of this pre-training cheaper. Okay. Anyways, back to the story. So Andre's Carpathy's repo also made it so that you could do all of this for $100. now $100 isn't nothing but I'll make a couple observations so first one is again compared to that other amount people spend more than that go play a round of golf you know go do something
you know it it is a lot of money I don't want to diminish it but it is enough like if you're doing it for learning if you're doing it for understanding if you're you know really getting into this it's attainable it's a hobbyist level amount that you could spend which is awesome on sort of relatively reasonable spec hardware and he has the scripts for doing all of it sort of set up, which is really awesome. But then, of course, the second observation I'll make is twofold. One, the cost for his stuff will go down. If you wait, you know, six months, 12 months, I would expect it to be cheaper as new hardware and instances and supply come online. But the second thing is as a general sort of observation, a lot of this stuff, this is where
you're seeing the growth. You know, we're not seeing chat GPT. whatever, five, or any of these other things become two X better, three X better. It's not really happening, but the cost to train, the cost to run inference is all coming down dramatically. And here, you know, I think is a little bit of an example of, you know, sort of the rise in the hobbyist stuff and the decline of the cost, you know, you're coming to, you know, not exactly at meeting point, but coming and converging together to where we can start to not get to state of the art, but push to something that five years ago would have been like, Oh my gosh, like you did all of this run.
That would be crazy. So it's a reminder of the insane progress we're saying. Yeah, totally. Yeah. I think it's a really good kind of recap. Yeah, I mean, this stuff's super exciting. I think a lot of the innovation now is, and I think Andres actually talks about this,
is around, you know, reverse engineering the best possible prompt. I don't know if I brought this up, but I don't think we have. I had a situation at my current job about a month or two ago. We changed models. So a model that we were using was deprecated. And so we moved on to the next version of the same model. And the performance went way, way down, like really, really far down. Like, went from maybe 80% to 7% kind of thing.
And after a lot of debugging and kind of, you know, looking at a lot of numbers, we realized that all we had to do is change the so we had a prompt that was about three or four sentences in a paragraph if we swapped the first two sentences the performance went back to 80 percent so so basically like the the ordering of the sentences the way the thoughts are and it's not like it wasn't illogical the first way right it was two independent thoughts and they just if you switch the order massive improvement and so what that says to me is that we humans shouldn't be writing these prompts. I mean, you know, we write the first version,
but like at the bare minimum, you know, we should have a system that just like reorders them a few different ways that picks the best ordering. Like somehow breaks them into independent thoughts and then tries different permutations. But at the limit, it would be, you know, some type of feedback mechanism
that's constantly updating all of these prompts. But that I think is where I'm, seeing kind of a lot of the innovation and I think it's because of cost exactly you know as you said when it costs 10 million to train a model um what we ultimately need and I think nano chat's a good way of getting there is you know a set of benchmarks and a set of models that are small and trained for very cheap um and then you can you know learn learn some insight someone can invent the next thing right like maybe it's SSM maybe it's a diffusion chat models right someone invents the next thing and then it's it blows
everything else out of its weight class but but it's still nowhere near chat GPT but but it totally dominates the very cheap chat GPT and so then you could say okay this is now worth spending 10 million I mean I guess that's partly where I think the running local models you know on your whatever home home smart device, your personal assistant on your phone. We were just checking before briefly. There's a cloud outage this morning. So that happens from time to time. And so I think having some of these models run locally.
And I think when they hardware get sophisticated enough and the models get distilled enough to be like absolutely actually useful in those things, I bet you would see a lot more investment into into that as like a focused product that you can have. Like, what has state of the art for a capped size model, not unbounded? Right. Yeah, exactly. All right. My news article is Pidentic AI. To be totally honest, I picked a random news article.
I really just wanted to talk about Pidentic AI. I could have made it a tool, but I had a different tool. So this is really cool. I used this the other day. I built a very simple test, like a prototype. So I downloaded, remember PC Part Picker? Yes. Remember that website?
Yeah, I don't know if they're still around, but someone posted basically CSV files of all the inventory of PC Part Picker. So there's a CSV file for heat sinks, a CSV file for processors, et cetera, et cetera. And I use Pidantic AI, which is this way to build AI agents, which we should probably do an entire show on,
but it's taking off, and I think it's very interesting. And I only give it access to one tool, and the tool is you know, DuckDB? We've probably talked about this. So the tool literally is you can,
you pass in which CSV file you're interested in, video cards, CPU, etc. And DuckDB SQL query. And this, this AI tool opens at CSV, runs a query, returns back the results. And so that was it. And so this whole AI agent thing with Pidentic AI, it was like 80 lines of code or something. And now I have this
thing where you can ask it to build you computers. Like you can literally type in, hey, I want a computer with the NVIDIA GPU, at least 16 gig of Vram for under $2,000. And it will actually build a computer for you out of all those parts and it runs SQL queries and you can actually see all the steps. First, it runs like a described select on each of the CSV file so it can get all the schemas of them all. And then it starts running queries. Sometimes it'll type in a query that doesn't compile. DuckDB will like send an error back and Pidentic can act will actually catch errors and turn them into strings and send those strings back to the AI. So the AI, like, got an error and was like, oh, I need to change the query. And it did. And it eventually
gets there. And it generates, like, builds PCs that are good. So, but, but I just found this amazing. And I'm sure there are other tools out there, but I just, I couldn't believe how in just a matter of hours, I was able to go from nothing to all that. That is really cool. I mean, it's really, like, commoditizing. Yeah, it's coming to the fact that, yeah, We can do that and it's super cool. Yeah. So if you're doing agentic stuff, this is the same company that made Piedantic,
which is a, which is kind of like a data class system that's very popular and really well done. Actually, the same people made SQL model and fast API and like a ton of amazing libraries. So this is also, you know, walking in good footsteps. My next news article is something that I actually botched and then it was amazing how it was amazing before it was amazing. Okay, here we go.
So I saw this news article and it was 1,000 Starlink after a launch this, again, this weekend from SpaceX. So all those Starlink satellites up. And there's been actually a huge thing like the amounts of money they're making. It's a private company still owned by SpaceX. But the number of subscribers, they have like as far as like a tech store. It's actually really astonishing. I would love to have invested, would invest. It's private.
So it's a bit of a thorny issue to try to get access. But this is a great idea. I'm really for it. But we saw this. I was talking about it that, you know, there's a thousand, thousand satellites. And then I was like, wait a minute. Hang on. Let me look at this again.
And it's, you know, oh, it was a thousand Starlink satellites had been launched in 2025 so far. So, but I thought was like, yeah, what I already thought was amazing is like, oh, there's a thousand of these satellites, you know, orbiting around. How cool is this? It's like, no, that's incorrect. There has been a thousand launch to this year. So then I, wait a minute, how many are there?
And it's like 8,400 and something in orbit. There are so many in orbit now that actually every single day, one to two Starlink satellites incinerate back into the atmosphere from. sort of end of lifing, which is expected. So they put them into, you know, relatively low Earth orbit. So there are orbits, you know, there's a little bit of air friction and whatever. They naturally decay. They're meant to do that.
You don't want them staying up forever and, you know, getting obsolete and then just drifting around a space junk. So they actually think they do a process for, you know, intentionally sort of making it. So they'll deorbit, you know, deliberately rather than just, you know, chaotically. But basically there have been so many gone up. going up that one to two every single day are just basically burning up and it's still this like insanely lucrative business doing all this crazy stuff and there are 8,000 found a visualizer you can click and actually see all of them because there's you know sort of orbit information is known and
it turns out orbital mechanics is like well understood so you can actually just go and visualize the entire like mesh of all of the orbits which is very well planned to get nice coverage You can see new ones that are being deployed are like clustered together and slowly drift to their, I guess, station. I'm not familiar with the term. But it's absolutely bonkers just to think about the scale of this. And I don't think maybe I've talked about on the podcast
before, but I was talking about it with some local friend group, you know, just sort of how if you had said this, you know, whatever, 10 years ago, like, oh, yeah, there's like this darling thing. It's roughly competitive with broadband. It works great. You can play video games on it. Like it's not super laggy. It's in this little dish,
just flat dish thing and people would be like what no that and then now people are like yeah of course that's called Starlink like yeah I have that in my cabin yeah it's it's from do they have coverage in the ocean or like do how does that work is it the kind of thing where it's only in places where there that can be populated or is it literally circumnavigating they have slightly different fee structure I'm not clear if it's because they can or because there's a reason but no people have it on like their ships on their traveling RVs on their boats yeah there and now the this weekend or whatever they're demoing and i guess maybe some people still don't know this but there was like a couple weekends ago or whatever they were talking about
one of the airlines i want to say united or american here in the united states was going to be putting starling dishes on all of the planes which they've used a different satellite provider so if you've ever gotten satellite on an airplane it's you know it's not very good yeah um But now they were like flying this reporter up and sort of they were able to take a FaceTime call and it felt like normal. And they were like from an airplane. And they were just like their mind was sort of like blown that, you know, flying through Spain. I think Elon Musk even ended up retweeting about it. And he's like, well, if you're traveling whatever the orbital speed, I won't quote it, because I'll get it wrong of a Starlink satellite.
He's like, even airplanes look basically still. And so you know, you think flying through an airplane like, oh my gosh, it's moving so fast. Aren't there going to be all of this? He's like, no, they basically look like they're standing still because we're flying so fast. Wow, that's incredible. And so it's just this interesting sort of normalization of what is just absolutely. It's rocket science, right? Like just all of this stuff, you know, being up there and going around.
So when the Starlink satellites are, you know, shuttled, is that shuttle reusable? Or like, how does that work? Yeah. So they do the Falcon 9. So it comes back and lands normally on the barge. So they go up, launch it in the second stage, the top part of the rocket as a fan go up. And they don't relaunch that. That's the new thing, the really big one that they make a big deal out of Texas, the starship and the booster that goes with that.
The full thing is supposed to be reusable. So that's like where they see the future. But for now, the first stage, which has most of the, you know, more of the rocket engines and everything. basically goes up and then comes back in lands and those are the videos you see. And so that's why they're able to put, well, part of why they're able to put so many satellites up in orbit.
But they still, there is some portion of the launch vehicle that doesn't get reused. Got it. Makes sense. Cool. All right. My second news story is the introduction of the apps in chat GBT and the chatGBT apps SDK.
I feel like this is really powerful. I feel like there's something here. So just to explain at least how I think of it, because it's still very early, basically, and I don't have a lot of details on it yet, I don't think they even kind of have a lot of details yet themselves. But the way I imagine this working is, let's say you ask chat GPT to play your favorite song, or you ask it to buy eggs from... I guess if you say from let's say buy eggs from Walmart right so right now if you do that
you know chat GPT is going to say hey I can't do any of these things would you like me to do something else it's always so polite it's like would you like me to just talk to you about eggs but you know in the future with these apps you will install the Walmart app
and when you ask a question you know the opening I folks will figure out from your question whether they should route that question to an app or not. And if they decide they should, it gets routed and now Walmart, you know, which probably is using ChachyPT
anyways, but like now Walmart gets your question and they're poised to handle it differently. So for example, if Walmart gets your question, they could order the eggs. They have your identity from you being logged into Chatchee. And so they can order the eggs and eggs show up at your house the next day, which is pretty cool. I do feel like this is kind of like a new kind of app store moment, which is pretty exciting.
I do feel like we'll kind of look back on this and say, oh, like, I wish I'd built like the, you know, whatever the most obvious app is, maybe groceries is it, I don't know. But I feel like now is the time to think about, like, what is the app that obviously everybody wants? Because apps aren't even allowed on the store yet. I think they're going to announce a date when you can start submitting apps. But you have access to the SDK. So if you have something where you think chat would be a better experience than going on the web or whatever else you would do, now is the time to build that thing so that as soon as they announced a,
the submission process you could be first in line. I do think there's something just extraordinarily powerful here. When this was launched, I saw it was like a thousand startups are killed by one slide or something.
It was like the headline. But I guess maybe, I like the way you explain it, I guess, if you develop your app, it's sort of like now you can host your own like server if you do something local and your chat chip.
Your chat agent can query your you know local server there's answering something so it's like sort of chat you do some training or upload some workflow or something and then open ai will route chat gpt queries to that internally if you host something there like if you is a state in their ecosystem can you run arbitrary code so it's not completely clear yeah let me let me see if like to explain it so the idea is you know you you submit an app uh open a i approves it now you're on their app store right So a person who uses chat GPT installs your app, right? Now, when that person asks questions to OpenAI,
OpenAI can route some of those questions to you. And you could then use OpenAI as part of helping answer the question, but they're now expecting you to respond with an answer. So in the case, like you said, So you're a grocery store. You do work to make sure that, like, your OpenAI app knows how to call your inventory and pricing, you know, Rest API.
And so you give all of that information or whatever to your subcomponent app. And then, okay, and then the user installs that one, which is why it doesn't have to disambiguate across every app on the app store. Okay. Yeah, I think that's right. And so you can also build tools like I talked about with the Pidentic AI. So in addition to being so open-ended that ChatGBTGBT just calls you with a string of text, you can also have a tool.
So for example, maybe you have a buy groceries tool and that tool takes like some very specific structured data. So like the name of the grocery and what quantity and all of that. I mean, you still have to do all the validation yourself because you don't never know what ChatGBTGT is going to call your tool with, but at least that might be more structured than, you know, you just have a string of text and have to figure out what to do with that. Very cool. Yeah, definitely check this out. I mean, I feel like folks out there, you know, especially if you're a hobbyist, this is like something to get in on early, I feel. Yeah, I guess that's the what the dozen fart apps on the app store that made. you know, tons of money in the first year of the Apple App Store.
Yeah, yeah, exactly. You need the equivalent, the chart GPT, chat, I try to make it chart, fart, GPT, I don't know, fart GPD, okay, oh, no, my, this is going to evolve, let's not do it. Chart GPT. Oh, stop, stop. Oh, boy. All right, let's just move to book at the show. We'll have to get rid of the friendly tag or whatever, the safer work tag.
I don't know we have a friendly, no, anyways, my book of the show, just hard pivoting. Segway, forcing a segue, is, I'm repeating, The Will of the Many, I had this book, I believe a couple episodes ago. I had only just started it. I have finished it. It was really good. I really like it. So I felt like I owed the people the like follow up that if I was going to pitch it as a, you know, hey, I'm starting this book. It seems kind of interesting. I did finish it. It is good, you know. And the second one comes out, probably by the time this episode's out, it'll it'll sort of be out so if you haven't started this um book and it sounded interesting from my last pitch i guess i could repitch it but anyways so uh you know definitely has like an
equivalent of kind of a magic system a loose magic system um where people can uh sort of seed their something called like a will like sort of part of their like energy their life energy i guess isn't hasn't been you know fully explained yet and they can sort of give it to somebody else, and those are assembled into the government in a kind of form of a hierarchy, a pyramid, and it's all about sort of the dynamics, the politics of that. And so, of course, you know, a story about a boy who's an orphan and ends up getting, you know, sucked up into intrigue and mystery and all of that good stuff. But by the author James Islington, who I've recommended other books from before.
Definitely something that I would recommend now having finished it. And I'm looking forward to the next one. I guess I could have made in my book of the show. But the next one seems like it's going to be really good as well. And I'm looking forward to reading that. All right. Yeah, I'll definitely have to check that out. I need to get more into reading fiction.
My book of the show is actually a podcast episode. I'm cannibalizing our show here. But basically, I had a long drive. So, long story short, it was just me and the boys, me and my two sons, and we were driving to Houston and back. And, you know, they're playing, you know, Nintendo Switch or whatever they want to do. So I'm like, I'm going to listen to a podcast. And I listened to the whole six hours of this podcast with DHS,
who's the person who made Ruby on Rails. I thought it was fascinating, actually. I kind of went in thinking, well, you know, this is somebody I have kind of heard about. A friend of mine told me we should have DHH on our show. That would be kind of cool. DHS, if you happen to be listening, which I doubt, or somebody who knows him or something, totally down for that.
But, you know, I'd heard of him, and I remember specifically him posting a lot of, about getting off of the cloud and he ended up moving to like a colo. So, you know, I thought it would be kind of interesting, but I had honestly a little bit low expectations
of just any podcast episode where it's just kind of a one-sided where the person just basically talks for six hours. But I was like blown away, actually. I felt like the content was really interesting.
actually the whole it really goes against a lot of the sort of like common themes that you're seeing a lot of. So for example DHH like despises going into any office
and so he's like remote work is the only work it's a really interesting perspective you know he talks about how to make remote work work well he's been doing this for like decades right So he gives a lot of perspective on that.
The company, which I think is called 27 Signals, they took $0 of funding. So they basically bootstrapped themselves by doing contract work. So they did contract work until they had kind of enough money. And I guess maybe they structured the contract work in such a way where they could share the IP. And then eventually open source the IP and it became really. Ruby on Rails and all of that. So $0
of venture, $0 of anyone investing. And he said something kind of interesting. He said, you know, people gave me a hard time because they say, well, you know, you, so their product, which
I forgot the name, oh, base camp. So their product is base camp, which is similar to Jira. And people say, look, you could have made Jira. You know, your product is is actually like in many ways better than Jira and Atlasin is like a giant company and you're this tiny company.
And his response is interesting. It's basically like it's a tiny company but you know, I own half of it. And like Jason, who's his co-founder, owns the other half. And actually like owning 50% of a tiny company
is awesome. And I have more than enough money and all of that. And it was like a real kind of like, I guess like it is also like I keep wanting to think of the word monastic, but it is kind of like totally antithetical to everything you see on social media. Everything on social media is,
look at this big round we raise. No one ever says, look at this $30 million we raise. We only had to give up, you know, 70% of the company. Like no one ever says that part of it, right? And everyone seems to be just like stolling all the virtues of being in person.
And yeah, I feel like just to have a different perspective, it was pretty mind-blowing. So I highly recommend folks listen to it. Also, my dad was a race car driver, so he spends about an hour or two talking about race car driving, which hits close to home, which I loved hearing about. That's more of a personal thing. But I found the whole interview fascinating, and I'd highly recommend folks check it out. It's six hours, so I think it counts as a book.
Fair enough. Yeah, I think 37 signals is private. I've looked before, I was just looking again to see, but I guess one of those interesting things about private versus public, and to your point, not only they have a lot more description, like it just don't have to share a lot of information and get judged about decisions. And so because it doesn't have investors or all of this,
like even people, you know, here are some hacker news posts, and they're just saying like, can we even estimate how many subscribers they have, how much money? And people are like throwing out numbers, but they're all, you know, just speculation. or you know based on some you know sort of swag at it like they're not accurate and it's just kind of interesting to think about like the amounts of stress reduction that would give to someone to say we just going to make the decision can we continue to pay the people who work for us can we
continue to make money that we're happy with and like there's always that question like what's enough you know and like if you don't have an answer to what's enough then maybe you just end up in one of these quests to, you know, seek power and fame and fortune. And that's okay, I guess, but if you can say, this is enough and he is saying, you know, I can do these really cool things, drive race cars and have this business that doesn't make me hate my life. Then, you know, that is awesome. It's great to see, like you said, sort of another way instead of it only, that there's only one way. Yeah. I mean, somebody said, uh, uh, the, the, the host, uh, the podcast said, You know, hey, one thing about working remote is, you know, it's kind of lonely.
How do you deal with that? How do you meet people? And the guy was like, DHH is like, get married, have a family. He's like, yeah, I have kids running around the house. I'm never lonely. You know, it's like, these are the kind of things that like, just like, just a different perspective. Like, I've never heard anyone give any answer like that. And, you know, it's so different. I'm still honest. I mean, we just got back from Houston, so I haven't had a lot of time to really, like, sleep on this. But it's such a different perspective that I have to really think about it. But I think there's definitely nuggets of wisdom there, absolutely. And I do feel like, you know, I've kind of ping ponged between, you know, I was in the office.
COVID hit. I worked remote for, what, four years. Now I've been in the office of the past year. And I do actually feel like, I feel like remote is better in many ways, but it has to be done correctly and you have to be in the right situation. So I think, I think remote where there is an office and like 90% of the people are in it, I think that's hard. Of course, you can make it work, but I think socially, like, it takes a lot of, you have to be very active on managing that. I think remote where everyone's remote or in the office, you know, it's, it's, um, you're on Zoom all the time anyways, because there's always, this is, okay, this is, this is my perspective.
Everyone's remote. Everyone's remote. Because you go into the office, but there's the Seattle office or there's Bob who's remote. Like as soon as, as soon as you have more than one office or a single person in the company who's remote, now you're remote. Because you're on. on Zoom all day anyways. I guess my thought here is similar to what I was saying before. I don't think there's one right way. I think to your point, it's situational. It's company by company. It's person by person. Some people hate like, I couldn't be at home. It's noisy. Other people are like, I can't stand the office. It's noisy. People dropping in on you. Like it's, you know, for almost any statement, someone will say the same statement in positive and negative light.
And so like anything, my, how do you want to say? My thought is you're going to have to try really hard to prove that there's a singular right answer and no nuance. Anytime someone comes and says remote work is the worst, it doesn't make sense, it never works. Or if someone says, and the office is dumb, it never works. We should all be. Like whenever you make a statement with no wiggle room, those are always the hardest to defend, right? And it's like, come on, there's got to be a gradient here. And, you know, and if there's a gradient, I think that, you know, I will say even being people fully in the office, having the setup that we could do fully remote means people have some flexibility to do.
If they need to take a week, a week, they may have taken a sick week or something away or they needed to, you know, I was pointing out, be home. There's so much random stuff where people expect you to be at your place of living for delivery or for some improvement or to come in or whatever. and then they change the date. So having some flexibility to handle those situations has been a net benefit, regardless of sort of what percentage allocation you spend office or at home. Yeah, totally makes sense.
All right. Tool of the show. Oh, man, I think I'm losing my voice. It's not good. All right. Mine is a game, and it's a game I am almost certain I didn't look because I didn't want to know, but I'm almost certain that I've recommended before.
Everyone knows it. Everyone has it, but I don't care, because I got sucked back in. I was free, and then I am no longer free. I've been playing factorial again. And not even, although it looks amazing, not even the Space Age DLC. I'm just back to playing vanilla, bass, no mod, Factoria. I've been playing it on my Switch, and it has been, it's always like a little awkward. It's so much better on the PC with the keyboard.
I will admit, but once you get into the groove and you're like on an airplane, which I was recently a couple of times, you know, can sit on the couch with the family, you know, when I'm watching some show, you just really don't want to watch for the fifth time in a row, which whatever. Anyways, like, if you can quote the show and like, you know what's going to happen from the kids show, you know you've seen it too many times, which means they've seen it even more than you because you know you haven't watched it every time they've watched it. um anyways i'm sucked back in factoria if you've not played it you either are going to assume it is either going to be work or amazing or you won't understand it i guess those are the three three outcomes be like this is just like work it sucks i don't want to work or you're going to go i don't get it this is like weird and and just like this is not fun or you're going to be like what you're going to spend 10 hours and then you have no clue what happened You know, I posted about a month ago, I had a friend, a close friend who's trying to grow his Twitter presence and just actively trying to do this. And he posted saying, you know, I went from 1,300 followers to 7,000 followers in a month.
Here's a list of things I did. And it was a list of things. And I replied, and I was like, how I went from 1,300 followers to 1,300 followers in three years. and it was a screenshot of Factorio. But Factorio is amazing. I mean, it's so satisfying. It's like got to be one of the most satisfying feelings, like building a factory.
I have a confession. I have like a probably, I don't want to look how many hours. I don't actually, maybe the switch does track. I don't know how to look. It's not prominent like on Steam. So I'm not sure how many hours I've played.
I've never launched a rocket. What? Really? Is that bad? It's bad, right? I need to do it. It's become like a goal. Like I, before I stop this time, I have to do it.
I just always do other stuff. I just, I don't know. Wow, that's amazing, though. Actually, it's amazing that, like, you have built all these intrinsic rewards, you know? It's like, oh, can I, like, well, give me an example of something that took you a long time that wasn't rocket. No, it's not. No, no, it's worse than that. I play for a while.
I start to get to, like, and it reaches, like, there's always someplace and it's always a little different where it, you need to, like, do. a bunch without like a good progression so you can like progress early game progress and I'm getting better I think actually each time and then I go away for a while I'm like I don't have time to invest to like double my output here build another one of these or you know get a blueprint working or get the bots going so I just like I put it away for a while or I get busy and then I come back I'm I don't remember where anything is so I just start a new game and then I just like start over and I just like do with all the improvements so it's just like what do you call like greasing the groove like just keep playing the early game over and over again.
I know, that makes sense. That makes sense. It's bad. I'm a bad person. Like, I need to finish the game. There's so much developer put in I haven't even experienced. My kids play with a creative mode where you're not even a person. You could just build anything anywhere and it's unlimited.
And you kind of like teleport around the map and they just build random things with it. I turn the biters. Like the biters are there, but they won't attack you unless you attack them because. yeah i just i don't know it's too anxiety inducing man well you know i mean you probably know this but the construction robots just totally changed the profile of the game like uh um like i i i have mine like near the end game mine will be set up where i'll have basically stamps that like stamp an entire screen's worth of content and so it's like uh uh uh uh uh like four robob ports a bunch of these like
electric towers and then a bunch of solar panels and it just stamps down and then because the robo ports are part of the stamp you know it builds the robo ports and then it can build the next stamp
and so I'll just walk across the stream stamping like hundreds of these and then I'm like done with power it's like okay well I don't have to think about power for the rest of the game nice all right my tool oh go ahead
my tool this show is nip.io which is apparently a great way to get in trouble at work as I still have no clue what this is so this is like I could see why workplaces wouldn't like this but I'll explain
what the tool is so the idea is there are many places where you know you can't use just an IP address you have to use a host name and so you end up in your code writing all these things like oh if I'm local then use like this IP address otherwise use this host name or you end up in weird situations where like if you're running on Kubernetes you know then the host you want to talk to you is just called database and you can like ping database you know curl database like from the other nodes in in that Kubernetes cluster
But then when you're not running in Kubernetes, now it's like, oh, no, it's actually a local host. It gets all confusing, right? And so this nip.io is like a cool way to turn any IP address into a DNS. So basically you take the IP address, whatever it is, you know, 1.1.1.1. And then you add dot nip.io at the end. and now you have a DNS, but it's going to resolve to exactly that IP address. So, you know, you're kind of trusting,
I will say that for the reason probably is blocked for Patrick, Patrick's job is that you're kind of trusting these people to convert that DNS to the correct IP address. So, you know, you might put in like 2.2.2.2.2.9.0.9.0.0.0.0.2.2.2.2.2.2.2.2.2. because the people behind that website have built like a DNS lookup that does that. But they could change that code tomorrow. They can make it so everything.nip.io goes to Google or goes to a web-based Bitcoin miner or whatever. So that is sort of a vulnerability that you're taking on.
It is, you know, it's powered by a company that seems like pretty reputable. but that is a risk. But when you're doing debugging stuff, especially locally on your laptop or you're getting started with a new project, it could be an easy
kind of convenient. Yeah, that's my tool of the show. But I could see, yeah, like you said, there are specific use cases where it would be really useful. Yeah, totally. There's a lot of code,
I mean, especially third-party code that expects a domain name that just will not take an IP address. And this is a way to get around it um all right so oh go ahead no no no i just yeah anyways workflow orchestrator we're gonna orchestrate the show here with a workflow orchestrator i'm distracted today dude we're just like i just like it's like it's like it's like it's like it's like it's like it's up over here um so so okay
Let's talk about why you need a workflow orchestrator. So here's a very simple example. And actually kind of spoiler alert, I actually asked this as my interview question. So if you ever end up getting interviewed by me, you're going to probably get this question. Let's say you're building YouTube. And specifically, like, don't worry about like the social networking
or anything of that, but just, you know, you upload a video, it turns, transcodes your video a hundred different ways for mobile and, you know, low bandwidth and all of that. And then when other people go to that URL, they get your video. So, um, video is maybe not the best example of this because it takes a while to upload the video. But, you know, you, you upload the video and, um, you know, then it has to go through and do a whole bunch of work, right? That transcoding of that video to other formats, maybe you uploaded it as a quick time video, which they don't want to serve that on the web, right? So that is a time-intensive
process. And so it's not practical to like just have someone wait on a web request, right? Because if that person just hits F5 or something and closes the connection, you know, how is that going to work, right? Those kind of two problems here. Problem number one is sometimes you have to do things that take a long time. And then problem number two is sometimes you have to do things that are kind of non-interactive where someone will leave and you need this thing to keep working and eventually report back in some way. And the last category of why you'd need this would be, you know, you have a lot of things, a huge batch of things that you need to do. So for example, actually, this is a very real example for us.
I went through and re-ost-transcribed all of the episodes of programming Throwdown. So if you look at the transcriptions, they're better than they were before. The old system I was using was massively out of date, and I felt like, well, since I upgraded it, I might as well just re-transcribe everything. And so, you know, we have 180-some-odd episodes. 184 episodes. And so that actually is expensive, but even if it wasn't, it's, you know, a batch job that I have to just submit a hundred of these and just tell me when they're all done, right? So that's the basic reason why you'll want to use a workflow orchestrator.
under the hood they all work more or less the same way so there's you know a set of message cues and so i think we've talked about pub sub and these things in the past but basically you know you need a way to submit uh jobs and um the jobs need a way to read your submission and so there needs to be some kind of cue to handle that um if the job is multi-step then when the first step is done now you know, a new thing needs to be pushed onto this message queue saying, okay, we're ready for the second step, right? A job can fail, you know, like AWS could shut down that machine, the hard drive could fail on that machine, etc., etc.,
and so message cues are important for, there's a lot of logic around, basically you send a keep alive to the queue while you're still alive, and if the queue doesn't get a keep alive for some amount of time, that you specify, let's just say 10 minutes, it assumes that you're dead and it will rerun, like it will ask another machine to go and process that. Okay, so message queues, a big part of it.
And containerization, another really big part of it, because you need a way to define some task on your computer, but then ultimately send that task out to the cloud, and there might be hundreds, maybe thousands, tens of thousands of machines kind of running your task. So it's not practical to like sudo app to get install some package all those times. So there needs to be some type of containerization. And then also the workflow, so the thing that, you know, tells, you know,
the overall system what tasks need to be run and which ones depend on which other ones, that also needs to be put in the cloud somewhere and containerized. And so that's the second ingredient. And the third and final ingredient is some type of worker pool, some type of, you know, a pool of machines that are ready to do work. And you typically pair this with some type of auto scaling. So you have, especially if you have bursty work. So imagine, well, YouTube is such a multinational thing that this wouldn't happen.
But imagine if you were building a version of YouTube and you're just getting started where it may be way more popular in the U.S., you know, you'd want to scale those nodes down when it's the wee hours in our time zones and then scale them up when it's peak hours. Yeah, I think that becomes important too for, you know, something going viral. So if your website goes viral,
you don't, you want to capture the signups. You want to capture whatever, right? So, but I think in that case, if the things people are signing up or doing or kicking off these workflows, I wanted to circle back to, you know, talking about failures, but I think there's a couple of things maybe that are less obvious or maybe important about these. So one is you were mentioning, you know, something like YouTube size,
but when you're kind of small, things generally fail because you did something wrong or there's a bug or a problem. But when you reach a certain size, even if, you know, if you look at what I guess is called meantime between failure, like you said, a hard drive or cosmic ray or whatever it may be, But when you're running a million, you know, jobs a day, what is the chance that at least one job is going to, you know, have an issue in a day? It's it's non-trivial, right? It's noticeable. And so you're getting these failures because someone is walking into the server room
and pulling out a server rack and like blowing the dust out of it for maintenance or whatever, right? And you can either have that be very carefully planned or just say, look, it's going to get handled. and I think kind of that is the same vein as you see stuff like I think Netflix was famous for doing chaos monkey something that goes in
and just basically kills off nodes or drop nodes to make sure you know nothing nothing breaks it just randomly sows chaos
I think the other thing that was my job when I was there that is my job in my family I'm just chaos monkey oh dad's here
Okay, wow, I've been distracted today. But the other thing is, you know, we were talking about, you know, and I think we'll get to it in a minute, but something like training and LM and it's, you know, $10 million. Some of these workflows could be very, very, very expensive. And like you said, imagine there's some error. But imagine the error occurs at like a very late stage. You don't want to start all the way again from the beginning.
So being able to kind of, it's not exactly a hot swap, but being able to resume the pipeline with a new, version of like a later node or even you just maybe it's not an error maybe the whole thing finishes but then you realize oh here in this last stage or this last but we could do better or we could do something different so having a system that automatically is like preserving those stages and inputs and and you know that kind of stuff so you can sort of rerun later parts becomes like super useful and tying that all with the dashboard and management which is things I have seen people not use one of these and then you end up just basically reinventing them
So you can either like not use them or you can reinvent one with half the features that you like do yourself. And you just slowly try to re and build a crappier version of like an existing solution. Yeah, totally, totally agree. Yeah, I think the part you mentioned about history and backfill is is super important. Like there have been so many times where exactly what you said happens, you know, the job runs successfully, but it wasn't actually a success. Like we actually went the past three days with no art. because, you know, maybe the upload failed, but it didn't let the job know that something was wrong. So, um, so for example, like a very common pattern is where you catch an error
in Python or in any language. You catch the error and then log an error message. And that's great in all, but because you caught the error and you didn't bubble it all the way up, now your job thinks it finished successfully. Like if you didn't set the exit code correctly on your program. And so, you know, that can happen and then you find out about it. Even if you find out about it an hour later, if your website's popular enough, that could be millions of jobs that have run in that hour that need to be rerun. So having all of that ledger and then being able to backfill and say, okay, you know, all the jobs from, you know, three days ago to now, I need to rerun all of them and it just goes through and does that and auto scales to handle it all that that's um that's and
there's sort of this uh kind of like um you know how cars have the uh what's it um there's basically like a backup system so imagine um so like imagine on your HUD imagine your HUD just like disappears like the the OS powering the heads up display on your car fails it's got some kind of backup where you'll at least see like the miles per hour or something but now that yeah right but that contingency that's where i was thinking of there's a contingent operating system in most of these cars but now that contingent operating system that really needs to not fail right because now you're really host and so similarly here you know the workflow orchestrator itself if it starts failing it's that can be a really difficult thing to survive right
And so to your point, you know, I've seen it as well where people try to build their own. And it happens so innocently, you know, the way it happens is, you know, you have some task. And this happens at big companies, you know, so it's not a small company thing specifically. Like, you have some task and it's relatively minor. And so you have this script that does it. And, you know, that starts to succeed. So it's like, well, you know, I'm just going to make a cron job and have it run this Python script every hour. And then it's like, oh, okay, now I need to run it every minute.
Oh, now I need like three machines. So I'll just spin up three, C2 instances all running this Python script every minute. And you kind of like, at some point, you have to just eat the technical debt and like set up a workflow orchestrator. But I've seen too many cases where people are going to go too long. And then when there is an issue, it becomes very difficult. I think the other term you'll hear with a lot of these is DAG, which isn't unique to these, but that all of these jobs form a directed ASIC, like, no cycle graph. So they're not looping.
So they have a start. They process some number of jobs with some interdependencies, and then they reach a conclusion. And so you'll hear them talked about that way. Maybe help me there, Jason. So, and not to throw a wrinkle here, but so workflow orchestration versus some that is more seen as like I would call like a pipeline like spark or something. What's the sort of distinction
between or where's a line or is it blurry? Like what's the difference between something that would be viewed as more like pipeline versus workflow orchestration? Yeah, that's a great question. I don't have a easy answer but basically I would say okay, one thing a
workflow orchestrator cannot do is it cannot fuse nodes together. So you kind of explicitly define, like, do this task, do that task, do that task, and they all depend on each other or in a sequence or something. And if tasks like B and C really could be fused into one operation, it won't do that because it makes no assumption about what programming language or what version of Ubuntu is running on that node or anything like that.
They're all just basically Docker containers that are getting spun up. you can actually, depending on the orchestrator you use, some orchestrators have it where you can spin up a container for a particular node, and that container can do multiple tasks. Let's say I have 10 videos. I have to transcode all of them to quick time.
I have a quick time node, and that node could do all 10 of them. Right. But by default, most of these orchestrators, you actually spin up a Docker container, do that one thing, that one time, and then tear it back down. And so there's a pretty heavy spin-up, spin-down time
for tests. Conversely, with Spark, like, you kind of create, you do create sort of a DAG, and same with early versions of PiTorch, or if you do PiTorch.compile, or, you know, early versions of TensorFlow, you would create a DAG of operations, and then what the Spark compiler or Pi Torch compiler
TensorFlow will do is it will fuse operations and it will create this super optimized bag and it does that because all of the operations are within its own ecosystem. So like Spark has a limited vocabulary as does Pi Torch. And so this being so open-ended, it can just run any Docker container with any arguments you want.
that open-endedness comes at a cost. All right, yeah, that makes sense. Cool. So, yeah, quick rundown on the steps to use a workflow orchestrator. Typically, you containerize your tasks. That's usually, you know, pretty straightforward. Most people are using Docker anyways. But you also have to containerize the workflow itself.
So the file that says, you know, run this task, and then, uh, run the second task afterwards, like that, that logic has to go somewhere. Um, and so all of these examples that we'll talk about in the future, uh, they all do it differently. Um, and then after that, you're kind of off to the races. You submit jobs. Um, one thing that is, um, that varies a lot from, from orchestrator to orchestrator is how to pass data among the tasks. So, So the early versions of these, the only way you could pass information was through arguments.
So job one finishes, and then it's allowed to inject some command line arguments into job two. But that's it. And because it's a command line argument, you can't stick like a whole JSON blob in there, a large JSON blob or anything like that. You couldn't put an image in there or something.
And so what you have to do for these early ones, is use something else to store everything. So, you know, the task transcodes the video, and then it doesn't pass the transcoded video onto the next task, which may be like sets a flag in a database saying it's ready. But what it does, it puts the transcoded video into some object store, like S3 or something else. And then all it passes to the next task is maybe a unique idea of the video.
later versions they allow you to pass arbitrary data but under the hood they're doing the same thing so when you pass like a panda's data frame or an image or something from one task to the other under the hood it's actually storing it an S3 in some temporary bucket which has like a low retention policy
and then pulling it back out for the next So, but yeah, that's all there is too. So it's really not that hard. I would say this is in the category of things that kind of like functional programming languages where it's kind of a unique paradigm. If you've never used a workflow orchestrator, it can look very daunting. But once you've learned one, now you kind of can do pretty much all of them pretty easily. I haven't used one, but looking forward, a lot of these names are familiar. So, uh, wait, really?
You haven't, uh, well, what about like a proprietary one or something? I'm sure you, oh, yeah, uh, I guess that's true, but I feel like it's a bit different. Like if someone else already has like all of this setup, I, I've sort of been a part of one of them, I guess. So other people sets up this stuff and I, you know, define some portion of some code that needs to run and someone is sucking it up into a container and running it. Yeah, that way. But I've never sat down and had to write in the language. of describing the workflow as an example. That makes sense.
Yeah, at Meta, we had something called Datastorm, which is very similar to the ones we'll talk about next, but I never worked on Datastorm. I was mainly mostly a customer, but they all are extremely similar. And I think a lot of these cases, like Data Storm's an example, there was something called, flume which was
similar to Spark kind of a combination of Spark and a workflow orchestrator and then that someone made an open source version of that but yeah I think most people will encounter workflow orchestrators it might just be a homegrown one instead of one of these ones
yeah that's true but the the big the big market share ones are Airflow. Airflow is an Apache project. I don't know the history of Airflow, but it's kind of the 900 pound gorilla
in the room. So if you're on AWS, there's something called MWAA, which is managed. I don't know what the W is, but the A's are Apache Airflow. And basically, you don't even have to set up airflow yourself on any computer or anything like
that, they just do everything for you. It's kind of like RDS for databases. So RDS things, you don't have to like install Postgres on a machine yourself or anything like that. They have the same thing for Airflow. Airflow is legacy. It doesn't have a lot of the features of the other ones we'll talk about. But you can feel confident that Airflow can do almost anything.
Like, if you can't get it done in Airflow, what that means is of the thousands and thousands of developers, nobody's tried to do what you're trying to do, which is maybe a sign that you're doing something wrong. It's kind of in that category where too big to fail, I guess. But it is legacy. I think it's originally in Java. And because Airflow is so open-ended,
you know, it's not hooked into any one language that well, I would say, is my biggest detractive. of Airflow. Some other examples, I used Dagster a lot. Dagster is quite nice. I think it's Python only, or if it's not,
there's maybe a Rest API that would be pretty ugly to use, but it's really meant for Python. It's nice, it gives you old decorators, so you can decorate functions as Dagster nodes. And so when a function calls another, if it calls a Daxter node as a function,
it'll return back a future, and Daxter kind of handles all of that for you. So it kind of pauses the operation of your function, calls that dependent task, and then comes back, and gives you your function back, which is pretty clever, pretty cool. So temporal is they actually just raised,
I think, a series, B. I'm going to double check. Yeah, they raised $2.5. Oh, $2.5 billion is their valuation. A series C, they raised. And it's pretty cool. So it's
kind of a different take. You don't have the dashboard. You don't have a lot of the things we talked about that are important. But it just gives you the bare thing that really matters, which is being able to run a function and know you're going to get an answer
regardless of how long that function takes. So temporal would be a good thing if you're building your own workflow orchestrator, I think temporal would be a good thing to build it on top of. And it might even be that Daxter uses temporal. It's very possible. But it is kind of like lower level, you know, really calling individual functions durably.
similar to temporal there's Apache Ray so Ray comes from this company called Any Scale Ray is also pretty low level so you're calling individual functions and it has to be kind of in Python
and so it's hooking in at pretty low level kind of like temporal the thing that's really powerful about Ray is just how unbelievably fast it is So with Ray, you spin up all the machines in advance. So, you know, all these other workflow orchestrators, you're spinning up a machine, doing some work,
and then spinning it back down. With Ray, you spin up a whole cluster. When that whole cluster is up and running, you then execute a bunch of functions, and those functions get farmed out to that cluster you span up for that particular task you're doing. and so it's a fully connected mesh of machines and then when you finish your task
that entire cluster gets spun down so you're paying a bigger hit up front but you're getting like super super low latency like you never have to worry once the whole cluster is up you never have to worry about any node requiring another machine or anything like that and the final example I have which folks should know about is cube flow
cube flow is similar in a sense to Airflow the big difference is they've integrated a dashboard where you can upload different statistics so for example Airflow is a dashboard where you can monitor the jobs and see oh I have five failed jobs yesterday QPlo has that too but QVlow allows you to like each run have a dashboard for that specific run. And so it's like, okay, task three,
you know, output a time series graph, and here it is. Task four created a scatter plot, and there it is. And so for workflows that are producing statistical outputs, that's like a nice feature tab. It sounds like some of them are, like you said,
sort of lower level. Like Ray sort of sounds like it's shorter, not shorter. You want higher, you know, response lower response times lower latency you want to be able to do lots and lots and lots of things you want to sort of shard them all up and have them sort of distributed and then other things like you were sort of saying like transcoding a video or something you pretty much want to like do a bunch of data reading do a bunch of processing kind of do a bunch of data writing
you know as far as like externally so you're sort of dealing with large blobbed objects and very long run times and so it feels it feels like there isn't a generic solution that just sort of like meshes over all of it, which I guess kind of makes sense. And as you were sort of saying, I think whether one sort of container can be multi-purpose or whether you really are needing different containers for all of the different jobs, probably plays a huge role in sort of like how easy or hard it is. Yeah, yeah, totally. It's one of these things that like the lines are a little blurry because I'm sure, I'm sure someone's going to email us saying, oh, you could do actually this, an airflow or, you know,
Ray could also do that, but just generally speaking, like, at the baseline level, you know, Ray is not durable. So if your Ray job, you know, you're responsible for doing checkpointing and things like that, you know, if your Ray job dies halfway through, it's just gone. Whatever checkpoint you have is whatever you created. You know, these other ones, you know, they'll just by their nature, they're constantly creating checkpoints. And so, yeah, there's basically several things you're juggles.
you know, how durable do you want these tasks to be, these parts of your workflow, and then what's your latency requirement, and then what's your sort of cost you're willing to spend? Because Ray, you know, for every... So just to give an example, let's say you have some type of task, and that task has a list of Python third-party libraries
that need to be run, need to be included. So if you do Airflow, you know, when that task node spins up, it spins up your Docker container where you've already put those libraries in it, right, and it's ready to go, and it executes your code, and that's fine. With Ray, you create a Docker container with those dependencies, similar to with Airflow, but you spin up an entire cluster, and every node on that cluster has all those Python dependencies. you know so if you have especially like heterogeneous things where maybe you have one task that requires torch which is like a two gigabyte pie pie file right and then you have another task that's just send an email you know that only requires like the base Ubuntu you know that an airflow is going to save you a little bit there so yeah there's no free lunch there's like several things to juggle I guess so some advice um I think Ray is, is, you should only use Ray if latency is important.
So if you're doing ML training, latency is very important. You have this GPU, it's very expensive, you don't want to waste time on it. So that's why Ray is extremely popular for, uh, training these AI models. Um, if you're doing ML stuff or things where you're producing a lot of, um, you know, graphs and a lot of those artifacts, I think Q-Flow could be a good, choice. And for everything else, I would use Dagster if what you're doing is in Python. Otherwise, I would use Airflow.
So that's sort of the workflow diagram of which workflow orchestrator to pick. Yeah. Can he's just all prescribed out for us? I guess it's called a flow chart. But yeah, okay. Oh, that's true. Cool. Yeah, I guess, you know, some like,
things to avoid other than rolling your own orchestrator is I think you can go the other direction and kind of make things super complicated with auto scaling and a lot of these other things. I think you can take baby steps
with these things. Just like anything, you can kind of start getting into it and end up diving super, super deep and saying like, oh, I'm going to preload the nodes with these packages and at the end of the day, like you know, this, you want this to save you time. You don't want this stuff to cost you a lot of time.
Makes sense. Thanks for the overview. Yeah. Yeah, the education. Yeah, this is a good thing to learn, folks. I think this is super, super useful. If you are looking to get started, imagine you have a, you have a website that has any type of job that needs to get done. I'm trying to have a good example. Like, you have a website that just OCR's pictures. Someone puts a upload, drags a picture into your website and you send them back some text or something in an email. And nowadays, OCR is so bloody fast.
Like, you can just respond instantly. But let's pretend like we're still where that took a long time. You know, just spin up temporal. You know, it's, I think it's relatively easy to stand up. I think they have a managed service too. It's very reasonably priced. and say, look, like, I'm going to call this function to do the OCR, and that function is going to do the OCR and send the email,
and I'm just going to wrap it in temporal, and now it's durable. And that could be just an easy way to get started. Cool. All right. Yeah, we hope you folks like the episode, and definitely keep sending us, you know, requests for new content, new show ideas. We take them super seriously.
we've implemented many of them. So our list is getting smaller. So if you have a show topic, please Slack us or Discord us. I mean, email us, however you want to reach out to them. Thank you, everyone. by Eric Barndollar. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons attribution, share-alike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work,
but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I, and share alike and kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.